all over India and Southeast Asia they
write with these squiggly loopy hangy
sprouty scripts but perhaps the only
thing cooler than the way they look is
the way they work a spice market in
India the hooded figure in front of you
apologizes for the kidnapping he needs
your help he explains that his land has
taken part in history's most elaborate
and rigorous memorization exercises
instead of scribes they had recitations
these weren't retellings of campfire
stories these were whole libraries of
knowledge handed down for generations he
says his name is Ashoka this is his land
and he is king after a bloody and
violent war he had a change of heart
and now has but one singular focus to
spread his message a law of tolerance
and compassion throughout the land but
he doesn't want to use the mouth to ear
memorization ways of the oral tradition
that's for old texts and old ideas no
his vision is to install massive pillars
around his empire each one engraved with
his list of edicts this he explains is
where you come in see he's been keeping
tabs on you as you roam the land of the
Semitic objects and he really likes this
crazy consonant alphabet idea he'll take
it but he also appreciates the whimsical
simplicity of accenting consonants with
vowel marks oh and he doesn't want to
have to write the vowel if it's just a
short uh his language is full of those
so he'll write funnel something like
this with these built-in syllables but
wait it's not fun Allah that final all
is in a separate syllable he needs a way
to write just bare consonants to tell
his past apart from his pasta how with a
simple hush stroke below the letter now
he brags to you his system is complete
make sure you don't miss the step he's
taking here it's a major moment in the
history of writing each of the character
units fundamentally represents a
syllable it just so happens that unless
the vowel and not syllable is a short aw
the vowel gets added onto or below or
beside the consonant character on their
own the base characters can
that dummy vowel up like ha but you can
take that PHA and modify it with any
vowel you like certain vowels go in
certain places like e to the side or ooh
below so in India characters are
syllables but unlike a full syllabary
you don't need a completely separate
character for each separate syllable and
all characters give consonant plus vowel
information but unlike a full alphabet
you don't line up sequences of
consonants plus vowels consonants plus
vowels the hybrid combination nature of
the system earns it the name alpha
syllabary combos are built into this
system paving the way for over a
thousand ligatures commonly linked
characters in the Alpha syllabary sure
other writing systems developed
ligatures in their calligraphy but the
index alpha syllabary welcomes them
naturally as it's passed all around this
entire slice of the world up to Nepal in
Tibet down the coast to Burma Thailand
Laos Cambodia and beyond the script
keeps updating its look but continues to
capture consonants and vowels accurately
like an alphabet and to write those
vowels consonants and syllable units
like the syllabary even completely
unrelated alpha syllabaries seized on
this same idea this is the ethiopian
bowl for MA
this one reads Mei and this is mu this
is law play and loop now that you
understand off with syllabaries you must
answer this next question if this symbol
sounds like ba how do you write BAE and
boo in Ethiopia this is your get is ABC
DS the abugida looks different but works
much the same way your characters have
never looked so different even after the
Greeks and Romans took them over maybe
it's this dizzying variety of writing
systems or maybe thoth's pill is
starting to wear off
you